شوارع امتزجت فيها الثلوج بالدماء جثث
ملقاه على الارض ومتاجر حطمت
واجهاتها في سوق في دونيتسك الخاضعه
لسيطره روسيا مشاهد التقطت بعيد ضربه
اوكرانيه كبيره استهدفت المنطقه المكتظه
يوم الاحد واوقعت اكبر عدد من الضحايا
بضربه في هذه المدينه منذ عده
اشهر اتصلت سيده من هاتف زتي كنت في العمل
قالت زوجتك رحلت لقد كانت تبيع في السوق
هنا في هذا المتجر على ما يبدو مرت من هنا
على الارجح مرت لان نصف الجسد كان ملقا
تحت الطاوله اخرجته
بنفسي وهنا في الداخل الروسي يشب ليلا
حريق كبير بمحطه للغاز دون وقوع ضحايا او
تهديد على حياه الموظفين وفقا لمصادره
محليه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت الاحد
انها احبطت عده هجمات بطائرات اوكرانيه
بدون طيار في الساعات الاخيره دون الاشاره
الى هذا الحريق في المقابل او توجيه اصابع
الاتهام الى
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا في الساعه الثه الا ربع فجرا
اتصل حكم منطقه لينينغراد قائلا ان الحريق
اندلع في ميناء اوسلو في مقر الشركه
نوفاتيك القوات الاوكرانيه كانت قد اعلنت
مؤخرا عن مسؤوليتها عن هجومين على النفطيه
على الاراضي
الروسيه